الان الى المشهد السوري والذي متى يتجه
الى ضوء لنهايه النفق بعد جنود القضيه
السياسيا لاثني عشر عاما فالمعارضه
السوريه ادت ليونه تجاه الحكومه السوريه
مصرحه ان الظرف بات مناسبا لاستئناف
المفاوضات المباشره التصريح جاء عقب
اجتماع هيئه التفاوض السوريه التابعه
للمعارضه في جنيف والتي كشف عن مخرجات
اجتماعها في اطار توحيد موقف المعارضه
المتوزعه على منصات الدم المعارضه مؤيده
لمبدا خطوه مقابل خطوه بعد مناقشه بيان
عمان واعلان جده والمبادره العربيه اتجاه
سوريا
[موسيقى]
لكن السؤال ما الذي دفع بالمعارضه السوريه
لتغيير موقفها قبل شهر ابدت هيئه التفاوض
السوريه رفضها التام لاعاده ربط الاواصل
بين الدول العربيه وسوريا معطيات جديده
غيرت الخط البياني للمعارضه الانفتاح
العربي على دمشق كان اخرها والمشهد الختمي
كان استعاده سوريا لمقعدها في الجامعه
العربيه سبق كل هذه التطورات الحراك النشط
والزيارات المتبادله بين المسؤولين العرب
والسوريين والذي اعطى صوره واضحه للمساعي
المبذوله لاكتمال دائره الحل السياسي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات